qué tal bienvenido de nuevo lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es una presentación
acerca de cómo esencialmente e invertir
la regla de la cadena para utilizarla
para resolver integrales para esto lo
primero que vamos a hacer es hacer un
repaso de la regla de la cadena entonces
recordemos que nos dice supongamos que
nos piden encontrar la derivada que nos
piden encontrar la derivada de la
siguiente función de f
de g de x espero que esto no te confunda
mucho ahorita vamos a hacer un ejemplo
concreto con algunas funciones
específicas pero imagínense que queremos
tomar la derivada de esto entonces la
regla de la cadena nos dice que la
derivada de esto es simplemente la
derivada de la función que está dentro o
sea g prima de x
multiplicada multiplicada por la
derivada de la función que está afuera
de la composición aquí es la función f
verdad entonces la derivada de lo de
afuera o sea f prima pero evaluada en lo
de adentro es decir f prima de gx ahora
esto de aquí puede parecer un poco
complicado si no estás acostumbrado a la
anotación no nos que hace muy cómodo
trabajar con ella pero vamos a hacer un
ejemplo y vas a ver que tiene muchísimo
sentido supongamos que nos piden
encontrar la derivada de lo siguiente
déjame inventarme un problema digamos la
derivada de seno
la derivada de seno de x cuadrada vamos
a hacer este problema
digo si quieres ver más ejemplos puedes
checar los otros vídeos de repaso de la
regla de la cadena pero en este ejemplo
efe gs x cuadrada entonces seno de x
cuadrada es esencialmente fg x entonces
bueno a ver cómo le haríamos para
resolver este problema lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es derivar la función
de adentro entonces la función adentro
es x cuadrada entonces y derivamos x
cuadrada nos queda 2x y luego tenemos
que multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo
de afuera acordándonos de nuestras
derivadas y la derivada de seno es
coseno entonces hay que poner aquí
coseno
porque es la deriva de seno coseno pero
avalada en lo de adentro es decir
evaluado en x cuadrada
sale esta siesta confunde un poco
recuerda la función interior y la
función exterior es decir cuando
aplicamos la regla de la cadena es lo
mismo que encontrar la derivada de lo de
adentro la derivada de la dentro sea 2 x
x la derivada de lo de afuera pero hay
que mantener lo de adentro igual hay que
mantener el x cuadrada entonces este es
nuestro breve repaso de la regla de la
cadena pero qué pasa si queremos
utilizar la regla de la cadena al revés
o sea como que en un sentido integral
entonces esencialmente lo que queremos
hacer que es tomar la integral de los
dos lados de la regla de la cadena
digamos la integral de algo del estilo g
prima de x x algo del estilo f prima de
g de x
saleh y eso de equis
ahora eso de ahí es igual pues
integramos una cosa que integra la otra
entonces nos queda efe gx como dice para
obtener esto pues aquí arriba aquí
arriba tenemos la regla de la cadena y
aquí abajo simplemente la integramos y
volteamos la igualdad fíjate aquí
tomamos la integral de cada uno de los
lados el lado derecho se va para acá a
la izquierda entonces eso es igual al
integral de lo de la izquierda que se
cancela con la derivada y nos queda
ajusta el fg x vamos a utilizar este
truco de aquí para resolver algunos
ejemplos para ver a qué me estoy
refiriendo con esto entonces déjenme
borrar la pantalla le voy a poner aquí
borrar para poder invertir colores
entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo pero
antes vamos a recordar que escribí atrás
entonces escribí que la integral de g
prima de x x f de f prima de eje de x v
x
es igual a efe deje de x esto
simplemente es la regla de la cadena en
la versión invertida que encontramos en
la diapositiva pasada ahora ya sé que
así se ve muy complicado pero vamos con
un ejemplo supongamos que tenemos la
integral la integral de déjame pensar un
ejemplo
a ver ahí va voy a poner uno que es como
medio truculento pero en realidad no es
tan truculento ya que no sabemos este
esta es la regla de la cadena invertida
supongamos que tenemos el logaritmo
natural el logaritmo natural elevado al
cuadrado dividido entre x b x entonces
bueno cuando ve cuando ves esta integral
seguramente es decir a está muy fea pero
no te preocupes en muchos cursos de
universidad incluso hay estudiantes que
no saben cómo hacer esto y también se
asustan pero lo único de lo cual tenemos
que darnos cuenta es que esto es la
regla de la cadena al revés porque
déjame describirlo como la integral de 1
/ x x logaritmo natural hay aquí en
falta una equis verdad el logaritmo
natural de x logaritmo natural de x
al cuadrado de x estos dos de aquí son
lo mismo sólo lo separé un poquito para
que se vea mejor pero el de la derecha
ya hace un poco más familiar porque cuál
es la derivada del logaritmo natural de
x si nos acordamos de nuestras derivadas
es justo
1 entre x lo voy a escribir aquí a la
izquierda osea la derivada con respecto
a x del logaritmo natural de x es 1 / x
entonces fíjate este 1 / x se parece
muchísimo a lo que tenemos nuestro truco
porque porque tenemos un 1 entre x y un
logaritmo natural de x entonces este
logaritmo natural de x lo podemos
considerar como la g de nuestro truco
esencialmente lo que podemos hacer es
tomar gdx igual a logaritmo natural de x
y pues con eso vamos a poder usar
nuestro truco vamos a hacer eso por aquí
abajo entonces ahí te va a ver tenemos
la derivada aquí a la izquierda la
derivada del logaritmo y entonces aquí
adentro está gx y eso con que está
compuesto está compuesto con elevar al
cuadrado
entonces elevar al cuadrado es f prima f
primas del truco entonces déjame ponerlo
esto es
es igual a haber aplicado a nuestro
truco directamente entonces cuál es la
integral de algo al cuadrado osea efe
prime se elevará al cuadrado entonces un
f es un tercio de ese algo al jugo
verdad en con eso lo vimos en el módulo
pasado ahora
es un tercio de algo al cubo y que tiene
que ir adentro adentro tiene que ir gdx
pero ya dijimos kg de x es logaritmo
natural de x
muy bien entonces bueno hay que
acordarnos verdad que nunca nos tiene
que faltar la constante pero va ya que
logramos hacer esto pues tú me puedes
decir así sal seguramente esto me está
confundiendo muchísimo y bueno es
posible que te haya confundido pero
vamos a derivar vamos a derivar esta
cosa de aquí para verificar qué es lo
que está pasando en el sentido de la
derivada vamos a derivar lo de adentro
para aplicando la regla de la cadena es
uno entre equis y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo de
afuera pero dejando lo de adentro igual
lo de la deriva de lo de afuera es
elevarlo al jugo y entre tres entonces
es tres por un tercio de todo lo que
estaba dentro pero al cuadrado y lo que
estaba dentro era el logaritmo natural
de equis y bueno por supuesto si
derivamos está constante nos queda 0
aquí ya no ponemos nada entonces 3 se
cancela con el 3 y esto es igual a 1
entre x x logaritmo natural de x y eso
de ahí elevado al cuadrado
eso es justo lo que teníamos al
principio verdad entonces con esto
verificamos que hicimos nuestro integral
bien voy a hacer otro problema porque
este estuvo un poco difícil déjame
borrar la pantalla pero antes déjame
hacer una aclaración o sea la regla de
la cadena nos sirve para encontrar nos
sirve para encontrar ciertas integrales
supongamos que nos piden la integral de
digamos
seno de x
y todo eso al cubo fíjate que es un poco
engañoso es la composición de dos
funciones esto lo podemos reescribir
como la integral de seno al cubo de x es
la misma cosa solo que escrita con dos
notaciones distintas pero no tenemos la
derivada de seno por ningún lugar
entonces no podemos utilizar la regla de
la cadena entonces hay tema déjame
déjame reescribir este problema para que
salga lo voy a tachar me va a estallar
por acá entonces ahí te van voy a hacer
un nuevo problema con donde donde
aparece la deriva de la función afuera
entonces tengo que poner coseno de x
multiplicado
jose no de x x seno de x elevado al cubo
y esto si lo vamos a poder hacer con
nuestra regla de la cadena invertida
porque ya apareció la derivada fíjate a
que hay un seno de x hay un seno de x al
cubo pero afuera afuera tenemos su
derivada la derivada de seno es coseno
y entonces como tenemos aquí adentro una
función y afuera tenemos su derivada
podemos tratar esta función como una
función solista como la g del truco
entonces cosa que pasa si lo pensamos
así déjame hacer déjame seguir por aquí
abajo esto de aquí es igual a seno de x
entonces
efe es elevar a efe prima es elevar al
cubo entonces efe es elevar a la cuarta
y multiplicar por un cuarto
y entonces como hicimos para hacer eso
bueno porque la integral de quizá la
cuarta de x perdón la integral de x al
cubo de x es igual a un cuarto de x a la
cuarta en vez de una x tenemos un seno
de x y la razón por la cual podríamos
hacer eso es porque la derivada aparecía
aquí afuera en el siguiente vídeo
resolveremos este problema haciendo el
método de sustitución y veremos que son
casi la misma cosa nos vemos hasta la
próxima